ce que je vais vous montrer ce matin
c'est un certain nombre d' attendu qui
sont à prendre en compte à partir de
maintenant pour piloter l'évolution de
la mobilité
quelle que soit la mobilité à laquelle
on réfléchit soit dit en passant une
bonne partie de ses attendus
ça c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle sont
probablement valable pour la grande
bretagne comme pour la france et plus
généralement pour la pac européenne et
ensuite on vous présentera un travail
qui a été fait par carbone 4 pour
proposer une méthode un décideur locale
quand il veut évaluer ex ante et les
résultats vraisemblable d'une nouvelle
offre qu'il proposerait aux personnes
qui habitent quelque part donc l'idée
c'est je suis un décideur locale j'ai
une situation de départ qui est ce
qu'elle est je propose quelque chose de
nouveau
vous verrez les trois exemples sur
lesquels on a travaillé est-ce que je
peux avoir une idée des encours de
grandeur du résultat est ce que je
devais faire que l'induction de trafic
est ce que je vais faire du report modal
à peu près dans quelles proportions et
c'est quoi les bénéfices ou les
inconvénients donc la coutume d'appeler
les externalités économique ou
environnemental de ce que je m'apprête à
faire c'est une méthode qui a été
d'entrée de jeu conçu comme du fast and
dirty donc l'idée c'est pas de faire des
calculs sophistiqués quand on a les
données on peut toujours les faire
l'idée est justement de proposer quelque
chose qui est en l'absence de toute
information contextuelle un peu précises
est-ce que je peux quand même avoir une
idée de ce qui va se passer voilà donc c
g 20 minutes réglementaires
je crois ne laissez pas faire beaucoup
plus je vous le disais tout à l'heure
la première chose le premier élément de
contexte dans lequel on se situer
quelque chose qui depuis contient des
statistiques économiques de type pib est
raisonnablement inédit en europe c'est
que si on mesure le pib par individu
là je vous montre en france mais en
grande bretagne ça ressemble beaucoup
depuis que contient ce genre de
statistiques de manière un peu sérieuse
on va dire le début des années 60
eh bien il se passe quelque chose depuis
2007 qui est inédit c'est une rupture de
pente
une rupture de pente une érosion à
l'échelle européenne certes le pib par
personne à l'échelle européenne est en
train de descendre et pour ceux d'entre
vous qui sont familiers avec la
comptabilité nationale il est vrai sens
abl du reste que ça irait encore plus
vite s'ils ont des flattait les actifs
comme monde et flatte les biens courants
cette tendance quand on la regarde
non pas en valeur absolue mais sur sa
variation c'est à dire sur le taux de
croissance ou de décroissance
elle est encore plus net vous avez ici
pour la france alors la légende est en
anglais nouvelle pour la france et
depuis 1960 la variation du de la
croissance du pib par personne la
croissance ou décroissance évidemment à
ce moment ça s'appelle une récession
est ce que vous voyez c'est que la
variation de la variation donc la
variation de ce taux de croissance est
très clairement une baisse c'est à dire
que la croissance du pib par personne
dans les années 60 était de l'ordre de
5% puis vous voyez que c'est descendu à
de l'ordre de 2 3% puis c'est descendu à
de l'ordre de 1% et puis maintenant
c'est zéro et vous avez pour l'avenir
évidemment un tout petit sujet qui est
est ce que nous allons avoir le rêve de
tout candidat aux élections c'est à dire
qu'on va revenir à la valeur moyenne sur
la période 2 % par an où est ce qu'on va
s'inscrire dans la tendance qui est la
continuation du trait plein que vous
avez ici c'est à dire qu'à partir de
maintenant le paysage structurelles ça
sera la récession c'est à dire qu'il y
aura chaque année un peu moins de pib
par personne
si on est dans la deuxième option pour
qu'une loi de la physique n'interdit à
ce moment ça veut dire qu'on se retrouve
a résonné dans un paysage qui est
totalement nouveau et en particulier une
caractéristique qui est extrêmement
importante pour la planification de
n'importe quoi c'est que vous avez une
double peine
si jamais vous vous trompez dans vos
choix dans un univers en expansion vous
pouvez faire à la fois des choses
intelligentes et des choses stupides les
choses stupides n'engendre pas d'effet
d'éviction sur les choses intelligentes
puisque vous avez assez d'argent pour
faire les deux dans un univers en
récession si vous faites des choses
stupides
non seulement c'est stupide mais en plus
vous avez perdu l'argent qui vous aurait
permis de faire des choses intelligentes
donc votre votre critère d'arbitrage
change du tout au tout et là je suis pas
en train de faire de l'idéologie
pro-croissance pour décroissance n'est
pas le sujet si on se place du point de
vue très pratique de l'investisseur dans
des infrastructures qui sont censés
servir la collectivité
et bien si vous vous trompez de choix à
ce moment vous avez la double peine
alors ça pose un problème important
qu'on constate en france je sais pas
s'il a
grande bretagne vit le même drame entre
guillemets ou pas c'est que la capacité
de projection à long terme de la
puissance publique est devenue quelque
chose d'assez désolant on va dire
et cette capacité de projection à long
terme résiduelles elles se trouvent plus
facilement du côté des acteurs privés
que du côté des acteurs publics en tout
cas c'est ce qu'on constate dans le
métier qu'on fait et c'est quelque chose
qui n'est pas complètement sans
influence aussi dans le débat de ce
matin parce que ça veut dire que c'est
celui qui a intérêt qui se retrouvent
aussi être en position de devoir
convaincre la puissance publique de
faire des choses qui paraissent
intelligente
évidemment c'est une situation qui n'est
pas toujours très simple à gérer
la deuxième caractéristique européenne
en ce moment alors ça par contre les
grands bretons ils sont bien meilleurs
que nous là dessus parce qu'ils l'ont
vécue avec leurs tripes et avec leurs
propres puits de pétrole et avec leurs
propres débats sur est-ce que l'ecosse
avec le pétrole de rester chez nous
c'est la baisse de la disponibilité en
pétrole en europe
cette baisse de la disponibilité elle a
connu deux temps en fait vous voyez
qu'elle a connu un premier temps après
les chocs pétroliers là quand la
quantité de pétrole consommé en europe
croît c'est très très vite ça s'est mis
à croître beaucoup moins vite donc il ya
eu un temps de correction après les
après les chocs
puis après vous vous voyez que ça
recommence à croître et ça recommence à
croître jusqu'en 2006 c'est-à-dire deux
ans avant lehman brothers
si vous regardez la consommation de
pétrole dans les pays de l' ocde ça
passe par un maximum partout deux ans
avant les deux ans ou 20 ans avant
lehman brothers donc dit autrement c'est
pas parce qu'il ya eu la crise que on
consomme moins de pétrole dans ma vue de
la manière dont le système fonctionne
c'est parce qu'on a moins de pétrole
qu'il ya eu la crise vous avez très
souvent dans les raisonnements
économiques quelque chose qui voudrait
que d'abord vous avez de la croissance
qui vient de mars et ensuite avec la
croissance qui vient de marciac demande
en énergie et on consomme de l'énergie
c'est pas du tout comme ça que ça marche
c'est d'abord vous avez de l'énergie ça
vous permet de créer des flux physiques
et ses flux physiques ont une
contrepartie qui s'appelle les euros et
quand on comptabilise d euros bah ça
s'appelle le pib donc c'est parce qu'on
à l'énergie qui permet de créer les flux
que derrière on a la contrepartie
économique des flux qui s'appelle le pib
quand vous avez moins de pétrole toutes
choses égales par ailleurs vous avez
moins de transports dont vous avez moins
des changes dont vous avez moins de pib
ça marche très bien
dans tous les pays dans lesquels vous
tenez ce genre de statistiques alors la
raison pour laquelle l'offre en pétrole
se contracte en ce moment en europe et
c'est une contraction subie c'est tout
simplement parce que l'approvisionnement
domestique à savoir la mer du nord est
en déclin
la mer du nord décline à raison de 5 à
8% par an et l'approvisionnement
apporter décline également parce que la
production mondiale est devenue
raisonnablement stable depuis 2005 à
quelques variations près et comme nous
sommes en concurrence avec la fraction
solvables des pays émergents et avec la
fraction solvables de la population des
pays domestiques des pays producteurs
eh bien les importateurs historiques ont
un résiduel un portable qui a tendance à
se tasser
si vous avez un approvisionnement à
porter qui se tasse et un
approvisionnement domestique qui se
tasse - plus - ça fait moins vous avez
tous apprécièrent l'école
vraisemblablement ça va continuer donc
en tout cas mon pari c'est que ça va
continuer et ce n'est pas le débat de ce
matin mais la baisse du prix du pétrole
va pas changer grand-chose à ça tout
simplement parce qu a pas de lien
historique entre prix et volumes sur le
pétrole
vous avez ici donc deux cartes
concernant l'île de france qui illustre
une des conséquences sociales liées à ce
que je viens de vous raconter dans la
mobilité si j'ai bien retenu les leçons
du professeur bretons en france à peu
près un tiers de la mobilité en voiture
c'est domicile travail
un tiers c'est des déplacements courts
pour d'autres motifs et un tiers c'est
la mobilité longue distance j'ai pas dis
des bêtises
la mobilité domicile travail est
totalement contraintes que vous avez un
travail vous y allez vous n'avez pas de
travail vous y allez pas et en général
c'est pas la distance au travail qui est
comment dire le 7 un critère mais ce
n'est pas nécessairement le premier
critère en particulier quand ces travail
ou pas de travail c'est pas du tout
premier critère quand vous regardez d'à
peu près du reste il n'y a pas de lien
évident entre le salaire payé à
quelqu'un et la distance qu'ils
parcourent pour se rendre au travail
j'ai eut connu des gens travaillant dans
des grandes surfaces et gagnant le smic
qui faisait 50 60 km le matin pour aller
bosser donc c'est est ce que vous voyez
sur ces deux graphiques c'est que la
distance que doivent parcourir les
actifs pour se rendre au travail qui est
figurer ici et quand vous allez du blanc
au rouge vous augmentez cette distance
ne recouvre pas la peau
mission des revenus des ménages dans
l'échelle des revenus de l'île de france
et vous avez en particulier une partie
significative de la population qui a des
déplacements contraints pour aller au
travail très long et qui par ailleurs se
trouve en bas de l'échelle des revenus
dans les revenus franciliens bien
évidemment ces gens là se retrouvent
pris en tenaille dans le scénario que je
viens d'évoquer
parce que moins de revenus en général ça
éjecte en premier du système économique
enfin - de pib pardon ça éjectant
premier du système économique les gens
qui sont les moins adaptable donc les
bas revenus ce qu'on a mis loin dans la
périphérie est par ailleurs une offre en
pétrole plus contrainte ça contre 1 en
premier pardon pour la répétition du mot
les gens qui ont besoin du de la plus
grande quantité de pétrole pour se
rendre au travail
donc ces gens là se retrouvent pris en
étau et dissertera pas ce matin sur les
conséquences électorales
mais il ya un débat intéressant à ouvrir
là dessus le cas de l'île de france
n'est pas isolée
aujourd'hui une bonne fraction à peu
près la moitié de la population
française vit dans une espèce d'entre
eux deux qui n'existait pas il ya un
siècle qui est pas vraiment la ville qui
est pas vraiment la campagne qui est
cette espèce d'air à structure de métier
urbaine
c'est à dire que le genre de métier
qu'ils exercent les jeunes qui exercent
les gens qui habitent dans ce genre
d'endroit c'est des métiers de type
urbain c'est des métiers de service dans
un bureau ou dans un magasin pour dire
les choses de manière un peu brutale
avec un tissu physique qui n'est pas
celui de la ville historique
c'est-à-dire r + 3 avec les bâtiments
collés les uns contre les autres et ce
tissu entre deux qu'on a coutume
d'appeler le périurbain ou le
périphérique en fait il ya un débat
sémantique intéressant sur la question
est typiquement là où nous avons décidé
de travailler en ce qui concerne la
méthode qui va être exposé un peu plus
tard c'est à dire on n'est pas dans la
ville centre historique où c'est assez
facile d'avoir des transports lourds
rentable on n'est pas dans la campagne
profonde où vous pouvez imaginer de
mettre tout ce que vous voulez comme
transports en commun en général
économiquement sa flotte pas on est dans
cette espèce d'entre deux où la question
se pose de savoir si oui ou non
c'est intéressant de faire quelque chose
alors fin du paragraphe sur l'entre-deux
vous avez ici la contrepartie économique
de ce que je vous ai dit tout à l'heure
sur le fait que ces ménages qui étaient
dans les couronnes un peu excentré de
grands pôles urbains sont ceux qui sont
plus particulièrement concernés par le
problème que nous allons évoquer parce
que c'est des gens qui ont des dépenses
obligatoires de transport qui sont plus
élevé que le reste de la population
et comme je le disais tout à l'heure
parce que c'est lié à l'accès au foncier
en général des gens qui ne sont pas dans
la première moitié de la fourchette de
revenus mais plutôt de l'autre côté
alors une fois qu'on s'attaque au
problème
il ya un milliard de manière de faire il
ya des gens qui disent on va regarder
des expérimentations terrain et puis on
va voir ce qui marche et ce qui ne
marche pas mais pour ça faut avoir
l'argent pour faire les expérimentations
et un peu de recul vous avez des gens
qui disent on va faire appel à un
consultant qui va nous faire une théorie
donc ce que je vais vous présenter
maintenant est un mix entre les deux je
vais commencer par de la théorie et
alors il ya une théorie pour ceux
d'entre vous qui ne connaissent que
j'adore qui appelle la règle de trois
qui en général est quelque chose qui est
très utile pour cadrer les réflexions
alors la règle de trois que je vous
propose par des émissions alors par pas
de la consommation de pétrole stricto
sensu mais des émissions de co2 retenez
que les émissions de co2 c'est une
manière agrégée de parler de la
consommation d'énergie fossile et ça
tombe bien c'est aussi une manière de
parler de l'impact sur le climat dont
deux présidents successifs celui du pays
et celui de la sncf
en l'espace d'une semaine ont expliqué
que ça allait être une grande affaire
d'ici à la fin de l'année donc voici
donc j'ai commencé par partir des
émissions de co2 et je vais faire
quelque chose qui normalement après
trois tasses de café devrait à peu près
pas c'est que ça petit dit que l son
égale à elle même
jusque là je pense qu'on devrait être
d'accord je vais divisé et multiplier
mes émissions de co2 par l'énergie alors
je fais apparaître ici un premier terme
qui est le contenu en carbone de
l'énergie et ça c'est le débat sur
est-ce que je remplace le pétrole par
des agrocarburants est ce que je
remplace le pétrole par du gaz est-ce
que je remplace le pétrole par de
l'électricité décarbonés parce que si
vous faites l'électricité au charbon ça
marche pas est-ce que je remplace etc
je vais tilly par l'énergie je vais
comme on parle des transports divisé et
x les véhicules kilomètres donc ici je
fais apparaître la quantité d'énergie
utilisée par véhicule kilomètres ça
c'est la consommation des véhicules
ensuite je divise et je multiplie par
les passagers kilomètres ici je fais
donc apparaître linverse du taux de
remplissage sait combien de véhicules
kilomètres j'ai par passager/kilomètre
plus mon taux de remplissage augmente
plus au terme diminuées donc toutes
choses égales par ailleurs plus mes
émissions de co2 diminuent et je divise
et je multiplie par voyage ou
déplacement donc ça c'est mes
déplacements et je ramène tout ça à la
population donc ce que je viens d'écrire
avec ma règle de trois c'est que les
émissions de co2 par personne pour la
partie liées au transport
évidemment sont le produit de 5 terme à
savoir le contenu en co2 de l'énergie
que j'utilise le la consommation
spécifique des véhicules que j'utilise
linverse du taux de remplissage des
véhicules que j'utilise le la distance
moyenne par déplacement des gens qui se
déplacent et enfin le nombre de dés le
nombre de déplacements par personne
question si je veux faire baisser ce qui
est à gauche soit parce que je pense que
c'est bon pour le climat soit parce que
je pense qu'on n'a pas le choix parce
que l'offre en énergie fossile et déjà
contrainte à la baisse qu'est-ce que je
peux faire baisser à droite de trois
très simple mais qui cadre le
raisonnement
la première chose que je peux faire
c'est dire je vais faire baisser le
contenu en co2 de l'énergie et comme je
le dise
tout à l'heure c'est je fais
d'électricité décarbonée je rappelle que
si je fais l'électricité au charbon le
résultat est pire qu avec du pétrole
hamas et puissance équivalente pour le
véhicule
si je fais mon électricité avec le mix
européen actuel c'est comme le pétrole
en termes de co2 par véhicule km si j'ai
des véhicules qui sont amassés la
puissance identique je peux remplacer le
pétrole par du gaz c'est également
quelque chose qui est en train d'être
qui est sur la table
et si le gaz c'est du biogaz évidemment
ça des carbones encore plus après je
peux travailler sur la consommation du
véhicule alors là on n'a pas attendu les
brillants consultant carbone 4 pour
réfléchir à ça c'est un truc qui est
récurrent chez les constructeurs
automobiles depuis très très très
longtemps
et à ce moment on peut réfléchir
diminution de taille démissions de poids
diminution de vitesse et moteurs plus
efficaces
et puis on peut aussi parler
éco-conduite c'est quelque chose qui a
un réel impact
bien évidemment on peut mieux remplir
les véhicules on peut diminuer la portée
des déplacements et on peut diminuer le
nombre de déplacements alors en ce qui
concerne le nombre de déplacements pour
ceux d'entre vous qui connaissent vous
savez qu'il ya une espèce de constantes
biologiques
en ce qui concerne nos déplacements on
est des êtres probablement parce qu'on
est des animaux et des prédateurs donc
ça fait très longtemps que on sort tous
les jours de la grotte pour aller voir
dehors ce qui se passe et quand vous
regardez le nombre de déplacements par
personne et par jour
c'est rigoureusement stable depuis qu'il
ya des statistiques qui sont à peu près
fiable qui sont suivis sur la question
ce qui veut dire que tous les gens qui
réfléchissent télétravail des mobilités
etc
s'il pense qu'on supprime le nombre de
déplacements en valeur absolue à mon
avis se trompent
par contre si on remplace le fait
d'aller au bureau par le fait de faire
le tour du quartier à pied ça on peut en
discuter mais biologiquement je pense
qu'on a besoin de sortir de chez soi
sinon c'est pas une prison quand vous
empêcher les gens de sortir de chez eux
toute la journée ça s'appelle une prison
en général on n'est pas très contents
d'y aller donc je j'insiste là dessus
parce que très souvent j'ai vu des
réflexions encore une fois sur le papier
qui était il ya qu'à diminuer le nombre
de déplacements je pense que dans cette
équation c'est le truc qui est le plus
difficile à faire je te que le plus
contre nature le reste tout le reste à
mon avis se discute
alors évidemment tous ces divers
critères n'ont pas la même non pas le
même potentiel ne sont pas activable
dans les mêmes échelles de temps et ça
dépend pas nécessairement les mêmes
acteurs par exemple si vous voulez
travailler sur le contenu en co2 de
l'énergie tous les acteurs de la chaîne
énergétique sont concernés donc ya pas
que les gens qui organisent les
transports qui sont concernés et les
infrastructures énergétiques c'est
capitalistique
donc vous allez parler de choses qui
bougent à long terme si vous regardez la
consommation du véhicule
là il faut pour que ça change la
consommation moyenne il faut renouveler
le parc en période de croissance en
france le parc mes 15 ans à se
renouveler en période de récession à mon
avis on sera plutôt à 30
donc le la rotation du parc c'est pas un
truc qui se fait soit enfin hors mesures
publiques qui prime à la casse etc
donc c'est quelque chose qui est
raisonnablement long terme aussi et ça
ne dépend pas que des organisateurs de
transport bien évidemment vous avez la
distance par des placements sur laquelle
on peut jouer sur les déplacements dont
on parle c'est à dire la mobilité
quotidienne
c'est très lié à la structure de
l'urbanisme et la structure de
l'urbanisme c'est également quelque
chose qui se déplace à long terme et
avec beaucoup de capitaux il faut
détruire et reconstruire
donc c'est pas quelque chose que vous
faites en une semaine on peut travailler
sur le nombre de déplacements et sarah
comme je vous l'aï dit tout à l'heure
c'est il ya un une barrière biologique a
pas de barrière capitalistique payer de
maria biologique et enfin vous pouvez
jouer sur le taux de remplissage ou là
c'est quelque chose sur lequel on peut
jouer dans l'horizon de court terme
pour la suite on va se concentrer sur
deux choses sur lesquelles on peut jouer
à raisonnablement court terme
ces taux de remplissage et consommation
du véhicule bien évidemment quand vous
passez de la voiture au bus par exemple
vous jouez sur les deux en même temps
prenez un véhicule qui consomme plus il
est beaucoup mieux remplis mais vous
avez joué sur les deux ans sur les 200
donc voilà je reviens à ce que je disais
tout à l'heure l'idée de ce qu'on a
développés c'est quelque chose d'un peu
rustique qui en l'absence de données de
terrain s'inspire de choses qui existent
déjà pour proposer quelques ordres de
grandeur qui permettent d'apprécier
assez vite où on se situe en termes de
pertinence écologique et économique sur
quelque chose qu'on aurait envie de
faire et on a travaillé sur trois offres
la première c'est les bus express qui
sont mis en périphérie ou en zones
périurbaines où enfin bref qui sont dans
la couronne urbaine
c'est à dire dans l'air d'attraction
économique du centre-ville pour des gens
qui sont dans un tissu urbain qui n'est
pas de type centre ville et ça ça permet
de jouer à la fois sur la consommation
alors par véhicule sale augmente par
passager ce à la baisse et sur le taux
de remplissage un deuxième
une deuxième offre sur lequel on a
travaillé c'est le covoiturage alors ça
ça joue directement sur le taux de
remplissage des véhicules existants et
enfin une troisième offre qu'on a
regardé c'est le transport à la demande
le transport à la demande dans la mesure
où il substitue une ligne régulière est
quelque chose qui joue sur la
consommation du véhicule
parce que vous pouvez mettre un véhicule
qui est adapté et donc ils consomment
éventuellement - sur le taux de
remplissage évidemment et ça joue
également sur le nombre de déplacements
puisque vous avez nécessairement pour
ces trois offres mais la question se
pose plus particulièrement pour le
transport à la demande
la question de l'effet d'induction c'est
à dire est ce que vous faites du report
d'un déplacement qui existait déjà ou
est-ce que vous rajoutez un déplacement
qu'avant les gens faisait à pied en
faisant le tour du pâté de maison comme
disais tout à l'heure et après ils vont
le faire avec un mode motorisés alors la
méthode est assez simple le principe
général c'est vous regardez la nouvelle
offre qui est amené dans un paysage
existant et vous regardez ses
caractéristiques intrinsèques donc en
gros le moyen que vous amenez qu'est ce
qu'ils consomment qu est ce qui coûte
qu'est-ce que etc et vous allez regarder
comment est ce que cette nouvelle offre
se compare par rapport à ce qu elle
substitue alors évidemment
pour partie l substituts comme je disais
tout à l'heure pour partie elle rajoute
il peut y avoir des effets d'induction
vous verrez après les hypothèses par
défaut qui sont prises pour les trois
offres qu'on a examiné vous allez faire
une évaluation du flux qui va être
concerné par cette nouvelle offre est
cette évaluation est assez simple à
faire à partir du moment où l'offre
existe et où vous avez pris une
hypothèse sur le taux de remplissage
vous avez par construction le nombre de
gens qui ont été transportés avec les
hypothèses qui vont derrière sur les
taux de report et l'étau d'induction
vous avez par hypothèse que vous avez
évité
après il suffit de faire le bilan et
vous avez le résultat à l'arrivée
donc c'est quelque chose encore une fois
qui est à grands coups de serpe un cd
addition des multiplications mais ça a
le gros avantage de pouvoir se mettre en
oeuvre vraisemblablement sur une offre
nouvelle en 4 minutes 30 ou à peu près
et ça vous permet de savoir très vite si
on parle de 1 10 cents ou mille et
maintenant j'ai quelques cheveux blancs
j'ai constaté que les modélisations
sophistiqué qui permettait de remettre
en cause l'ordre de grandeur initiale
que vous avez bâti à grands coups de
règle de trois c'est pas fréquent qu'en
général la première règle de trois vous
vous situez assez vite
là où vous vous trouvez si vous n'avez
pas fait d'erreur dans les éléments du
système que vous prenez en considération
en général c'est ça le c'est ça la
limite au raisonnement et floristique
alors la première offre comme je le
disais qu'on a regardé ses les bus
express dont vous avez ici un exemple
que certains d'entre vous connaissent
bien qui est celui de la 14 alors les
quelques éléments d'ordre de grandeur
qui sont proposés par défaut dans la
méthode rodée en gros si vous avez les
éléments qui sont propres à votre enfant
vous savez quelle est la gare construite
par vinci construction très cher
évidemment faut faire beaucoup de pib
pour faire plaisir à monsieur macron si
vous savez quels sont les aménagements
de voirie qui ont été faits qui etc
vous avez les moyens et le trafic
prévisionnel vous avez les moyens de
connaître votre coûts d'infrastructure
par passager kilomètre
si vous n'avez pas les moyens on a fait
un échantillonnage d'un certain nombre
de trucs existants puis on vous dit
prenez donc 0 5 centime par passager
kilomètre et vous n'êtes pas très loin
de la vérité
voilà c'est ça l'idée en ce qui concerne
le carburant vous prenez un engin qui
consomment 30 litres au cent parce que
vous êtes à vitesse stabilisée sur
autoroute
et avec un litre 1 euro 5 ans dont vous
voyez on avait été conservateur 17
passagers par véhicule etc
si vous n'avez pas d'idée particulière
prenez donc 2,6 ou 3 centimes par
passager kilomètre pour le carburant
vous n'êtes pas très loin de la vérité
en ce qui concerne le chauffeur pour le
moment ces emplois sont encore payés au
salaire à peu près médian dans ce pays
donc voilà ce que ça vous coûte par
passager kilomètre
et enfin bien évidemment il faut acheter
le véhicule et ça ça vous met aussi les
coûts par passager kilomètre et donc ce
qu'on vous dit ceci vous n'avez pas
d'idée particulière sur la question
prenait donc 8 centimes par passager
kilomètre et vous n'êtes pas très loin
de la vérité
ça sera pas 80 et ça sera pas 08 pas
très loin de la vérité
en ce qui concerne le co2 le co2
d'infrastructures et le co2 de
construction du véhicule pour ce genre
d'offre ne déplace le résultat global
que de 10 ou 15%
donc ce qui va vraiment content et c'est
la consommation du véhicule et la
consommation du véhicule pour ce genre
d'offre vous amène à quelques dizaines
de grammes donc vous n'avez pas d'idée
prenez donc 50
c'est très dépendant du taux de
remplissage évidemment ensuite ça va
déplacer des modes concurrent alors
qu'est ce que vous avez comme mode
concurrents la voiture là c'est toujours
pareil
si vous n'avez pas d'idées prenez donc
26 et si vous n'avez pas d'idée prenait
donc 190 grammes par passager kilomètre
ça intègre la construction de la voiture
c'est pour une future moyenne ça intègre
le taux de remplissage moyen sur les
déplacements courts du quotidien qui est
évidemment inférieur au taux de
remplissage moyen national qui intègre
aussi la longue distance donc les
vacances où vous êtes bien remplie enfin
vous êtes bien remplie voiture est bien
rempli ça va déplacer si on a déjà du
train donc une partie des gens qui se
déplaçait en train n'importe quoi entre
0 et 100 %
disons qu'ils sont donc bus ne prendront
plus le train et prendront le bus et
enfin ça va déplacer des gens qui
faisait en parcours de manière plus
compliqué en bus urbains parce que il ya
déjà des bouts de lignes dans un certain
nombre d'endroits qui permettent de
faire c'est pas nécessairement beaucoup
de personnes mais ça peut aussi se
présenter
toujours pareil vous n'avez pas d'idée
prenez ces valeurs par défaut
ensuite il faut poser des hypothèses sur
les reports modaux alors ce qu'on dit
nous c'est en gros il ya que deux cas de
figure à considérer pour un bus express
ou bien à votre territoire présente déjà
une offre ferrée où il en présente pas
s'ils ne présentent pas d'offre ferrer
l'essentiel des gens vous allez
retrouver dans votre bus je rappelle que
c'est un bus qui est fait pour servir de
la mobilité quotidienne
donc là dedans et en particulier aux
heures de pointe donc c'est vous allez
avoir peu de gens qui vont faire leurs
courses là dedans et personne qui va
partir en vacances donc vous allez
essentiellement récupérer des gens qui
viennent de la voiture quelques
personnes qui viennent d'un autre bus et
on considère en première approximation
qui a pas d'induction de trafic avec ce
genre d'offre du autrement vous allez
trouver assez peu de gens qui décident
de prendre le bus pour aller faire un
tour parce que ça va leur changer les
idées votre bus va être essentiellement
rempli avec des gens qui vont vraiment
au travail ou faire leurs études ce qui
s'assimile évidemment domicile travail
si vous avez déjà une offre ferme sur la
base
alors ça c'est provisionnelle sur la
base de quelques il ya peu
d'échantillons mais sur la base de
quelques échantillons qu'on a on
considère qu'il ya un report modal
significatif en provenance du ter et
mais qui a toujours pas d'indications
trafic alors encore une fois ça c'est
pour vous donner une idée si vous n'avez
pas de chiffres précis sur le territoire
si vous avez les moyens de vous payer
une très fine étude de marché qui permet
de savoir à l'avancé ce que z % de la
population on va quitter le ter pour
aller dans le bus va vous prenez
évidemment z ça encore une fois c'est
pour sentir les ordres de grandeur eq
santé et du coup vous avez des résultats
en ce qui concerne les moyennes des
coûts de transport par personne qui se
retrouvera dans le bus et c'est
évidemment une moyenne pondérée de ce
qui provient des autres modes donc ça
vous donne une moyenne pondérée que vous
pouvez utiliser pour mettre en face de
votre nouvelle offre
et voilà quel est le bilan de la faire
donc en gros vous avez le bus tout à
gauche
le référentiel qui est là la
combinatoire que vous avez fait avec les
offres qui ont été reportés celle qui
était utilisée avant et qui sont
reportés et vous avez à l'arrivée le
bihan alors il ya un débat évidemment
qu'on pourrait avoir qui est est ce que
quand vous mettez une nouvelle offre ça
vous supprime la part d'amortissement
sur les offres existantes évidemment non
vous n'allez pas supprimer
l'infrastructure donc mais même si on se
limite à l'aspect marginal c'est à dire
l'énergie et les émissions de co2 vous
voyez quand même que dans ce cas précis
par exemple c'est quelque chose qui est
intéressant globalement et en
particulier si vous n'avez pas d'offre
ferrer c'est extrêmement intéressant de
faire ce genre de choses et en termes de
capitaux s'est considérablement plus
light que de faire une offre ferrer et
s'est considérablement plus modulaire
c'est à dire que si vous vous êtes
trompés sur l'endroit où vous avez mis
les arrêts c'est assez rapide de
reconfigurer la desserte de votre
territoire donc typiquement quand vous
regardez on en parlera peut-être un plus
haut un peu plus tard alors je suis
désolé pour nos amis londoniens l'offre
madrilène qui est celle qu'en général on
cite en exemple vous voyez que avec des
investissements qui sont pas extrêmement
élevé eh bien on arrive à capter un
trafic extrêmement significatif sur les
déplacements pendulaires
voilà donc là on a regardé trois cas de
figure alors qu'avant je vous avais
donné les indicateurs unitaire là vous
avez les bilans globaux et donc bon je
vous laisserai le truc diffusera donc
voulu redorer les chiffres qui sont là
qui sont évidemment indicatif
après on peut s'intéresser au
covoiturage alors pareil on pose des
hypothèses
donc le covoiturage on dit quand il est
fait aux heures domicile travail ou
domicile études
c'est essentiellement du report modal à
cette heure là personne ne part voir
ailleurs le temps qu'il fait il s'agit
bien de covoiturage courtes distances
on considère que l'induction de trafic
donc est faible à négligeable et les
investissements sont très léger il faut
éventuellement construire quelques
parkings mettre en place un site
internet etc
l'essentiel des investissements qui
s'appelle réseaux de télécoms et
smartphones pour tous ont déjà été fait
par ailleurs part les personnes
concernées là c'est pareil vous voyez le
genre de le genre de bilan auquel on
peut arriver et bien évidemment avec les
hypothèses qui sont posées on a une
baisse
c'est logique les gens ne prennent plus
leur voiture et pas de celle du voisin
si puisque s'est posée par part alors ça
c'est l'effet de court terme l'effet de
moyen terme restent ouverts enfin la
question reste ouverte
il ya vraisemblablement un peu
d'induction de trafic à moyen terme
voilà donc le bilan qu'on tire des
quelques cas qu'on a regardé c'est que
le bus express et le covoiturage pour
les déplacements du quotidien sont des
solutions qui sont intéressantes donc la
question évidemment et comment ça peut
se développer l'offre de transport à la
demande on a regardé des trucs alors
c'est beaucoup plus limité dans les
volumes que ça concerne aujourd'hui
c'est vraiment une offre de territoire
rural plus que deux territoires urbains
c'est voilà donc ces et puis je dirais
les hypothèses par défaut à poser sur le
transport à la demande et en particulier
la part d'un duction c'est beaucoup plus
difficile d'avoir une hypothèque par
défaut dont on se dit celle-là c'est la
bonne on est très confiants là dessus
par contre ça une utilité sociale quand
vous regardez les gens qui se déplacent
dans ce genre d'offre c'est très souvent
des gens qui n'ont pas ou plus accès à
la voiture comme chauffeur soit qu'ils
sont trop vieux soit qu'ils sont trop
jeunes voilà là on vous a présenté
encore une fois quelque chose de fast
and dirty sur des offres assez simple
après il peut y avoir des offres plus
compliqué dans lesquelles la prise en
compte des éléments supplémentaires et
quelque chose quitter qui qui peut être
un peu moins simple
par exemple si vous commencez à avoir
des infrastructures dédiées à ce moment
il faut les intégrer les valeurs par
défaut sont pas nécessairement
il faut les calculs et alors vous pouvez
avoir des systèmes un peu dynamique pour
le covoiturage vous montre un exemple
juste après et puis plus vous aller vers
des choses exotiques évidemment et plus
enfin la méthode peut toujours
s'appliquer à des choses exotiques par
contre le fait d'avoir des valeurs par
défaut qui sont souvent issus de
l'observation devient d'autant plus
difficile que ça a été peu expérimentés
c'est une évidence que je veux dire donc
voilà un exemple de covoiturage
dynamique
le covoiturage dynamique s'est il n'y a
pas juste un point de chargement et
quelques points où peu de points de
déchargement en gros c'est une espèce
d'hubert quoi je fais désolé de
prononcer ce mot aujourd'hui
dit autrement vous avez une espèce de
validité permanente de l'offre et
d'adaptation un peu de place de marché
on va dire un peu permanente et en plus
vous avez c'est comme dans une vraie
place de marché vous avez des futurs
donc l'utilisateur potentiel peut
évaluer ses chances de succès s'ils
souhaitent se déplacer plus tard dans le
temps avec une analyse prévisionnelle de
l'offre qui pourra trouver à ce moment
là